[Musik]
me und her diese die 12 Uhr gepant
gehenüber nach Berlin zu her
[Applaus]
[Musik]
R ich hoffe sie hören was meine Damen
und
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Herren kriegenr meen und
her ist dass man dass es relativ laut
ist wir hören da mal rein mal sehen ob
wir das ihnen rüberbringen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
können also meine Damen und Herren wir
haben kein Einfluss auf das Bild dass
wir Ihnen hier zeigen nur dass sie sich
nicht wundern aber wir haben aus Berlin
schon gehört es sollen hunderte
Traktoren schon dort sein es waren etwa
3000 Menschen angemeldet zu dieser Demo
das ist schon beeindruckend in das ja
doch relativ kurzfristig dieser Aufruf
kam Ende letzter Woche von äh der
Agrarindustrie und dem Deutschen
Bauernverband für den dann Joachim
ruckwied als Präsident des Deutschen
Bauernverbandes hier dann gleich reden
wird noch mal das was ich ihn eben schon
angedeutet habe also abgesehen davon
dass die Subventionen fallen sollen für
den Agrardiesel also für die Land und
forstwirtschaftlichen Maschinen soll ja
auch die
kfzsteuer Fallen und J Ö mir der Landes
der
bundesagrarminister hat sich ja schon
dagegen ausgesprochen so beides auf
einmal zu machen wir hören mal rein wie
vor Ort die Stimmungslage und die
Meinungslage der Beteiligten
ist ja also ich bin jetzt hier weil ich
derzeit im dritten Ausbildungsjahr bin
und für mich durch diese ganze grüne
Ideologie einfach keine Chance mehr
besteht irgendwie zu handeln wir
versuchen ja alles bestmögliche ich habe
kein elälterlichen Betrieb und deswegen
muss ich mir meine Arbeit suchen und
wenn die Arbeitsplätze wegfallen dann
sind ganz viele junge Auszubildende
einfach ohne Betrieb und wir wollen
diese Landwirtschaft weiterführen weil
ohne Landwirtschaft gibt's kein Essen
gibt's einfach uns alle nicht und ich
glaube das verstehen die Gewerke
heutzutage auch alle also ohne uns
wird's nichts mehr und es gibt so viele
Leute
die brauchen einfach diesen Job und wir
brauchen alle unser Essen ohne uns
geht's einfach nicht ja es ist jetzt der
Tropfen an Sie alle herzlich willkommen
hier in Berlin herzlich willkommen zur
Demonstration
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schie liebe
beuerinnen sie sind hier vor Weihnachten
aus der ganzen Republik
angereist Vorlaufszeit dre Tage tausende
buerinnen und Bauern tausende Menschen
die unsere Interessen unterstützen
mehrere tausend Traktoren das ist eine
Ansage an die Berliner Regierung dass
das so nicht mehr weiter kan es
reicht die
Demonstration ist von Deutschen
Bauernverband organisiert
bzw dazu eingeladen worden wir werden
aber zahlreich
unterstützt insbesondere von LSV die
hier sehr stark s herzlich
willkommen aber auch freie Bauern
ABL sämtliche etablierten Organisationen
aus der Land und Forstwirtschaft
Gemüsebau Weinbau die Tierhalter alle
sind sie hier in Berlin um eins zu sagen
es ist Schluss es reicht zu viel ist zu
viel Bundeskanzler
Scholz Wirtschaftsminister habck und
nicht zuletzt Finanzminister
Lindner wollen uns
zusätzlich wollen uns Bauern die
Landwirtschaft zusätzlich mit einer
Milliarde Euro per anum pro Jahr mit
höheren Steuern belasten das ist eine
Kampfansage und diese Kampfansage nehmen
wir
an heute nur der Auftakt das ist die
Botschaft an die
Bundesregierung und wir sind nicht nur
hier in Berlin wir sind auch heute schon
vor Ort mit vielen Traktoren und wenn
die
Bundesregierung diese
unzumutbaren Vorschläge und ich meine
den Vorschlag zur Besteuerung unserer
Fahrzeuge und den Vorschlag zum
marardiesel nicht zurücknimmt werden wir
ab 8 Januar dafür sorgen egal ob es
Winter ist oder nicht dass es einen
heißen einen sehr heißen Januar geben
wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind schon
belastet mit mehreren 100 Millionen Euro
pro Jahr an
zusätzlichen Abgaben bzw Kürzungen ich
nenne die Kürzung zur
landwirtschaftlichen
Berufsgenossenschaft über 70 Millionen
Euro die Kürzung bei der
Gemeinschaftsaufgabe Agrarstruktur und
Küstenschutz an
Millionen EUR das ist schon eine massive
nicht hinnehmenbare Belastung aber das
was jetzt vorgeschlagen ist das schlägt
dem fast den Boden
aus das Ganze steht unter dem Stichwort
Haushaltskonsolidierung müssen
sparen schauen wir uns mal den Haushalt
an Deutschland hatte noch nie so hohe
Steuereinnahmen wie jetzt die
Steuereinnahmen sprudeln das ist kein
einnahmenproblem das ist ein
Ausgabenproblem Liebe bäerinnen und
[Applaus]
Bauern
tschasminister
hab
Bundeswirtschaftsminister
habbeck steht dazu
unterstreich das ganze noch ich kann ihm
nur einen Rat geben da Außenministerin
annaalena berbur zu empfehlen dass Sie
nicht weiterhin deutsches Steuergeld in
anderen Ländern verschenkt
jawohl
diese Politik in der Form muss ein Ende
haben das Steuergeld muss vorrangig
dafür verwendet werden dass Deutschland
eine Zukunft hat dass die Menschen die
die Steuerlast erbringen und deren
Kinder und Enkel eine Zukunft haben
damit wir Bauern die Bauernfamilien eine
Zukunft
haben
deutses für deutsche Bürger
das die Demonstration hat es fast zum
Überlaufen
gebracht vieles ist der Landwirtschaft
in der Vergangenheit zugemutet
worden auch vor der jetzigen Legislatur
beispielsweise
zenschutzverordnung
etc aber das ist jetzt zu viel und ich
sage an dieser Stelle wir nehmen das
nicht mehr hin wir nehmen den Kampf an
und ich bin mir sicher ich bin mir
sicher andere Berufsgruppen werden zu
uns aufschließen das
Transportgewerbe
die
Gastronomie und viele andere auch wir
brauchen eine anders
ausgerichtete
Regierungspolitik wenn das nicht kommt
das sage ich so deutlich dann brauchen
wir einen
Regierungswechsel
her
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister
östemier
[Musik]
Rest Liebe bäerinnen und
Bauern wir sind alle sehr gut
erzogen wir wissen was ich
gehört und
deshalb und
deshalb Herr Bundesland
Landwirtschaftsminister
östemier Respekt dass Sie heute hier
sind Respekt dass sie sich den Bauern
und
Bäuerinnen Stellen
Respekt und ich weiß auch und ich weiß
auch dass Sie von Anfang an was den
Agrardiesel und die Streichung
anbelangt gewarnt haben
aber eines muss ich in der Deutlichkeit
sagen wir
erwarten von einem
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister dass er
sich mit ganzer Kraft mit Herzblut für
die für die er Verantwortung trägt
nämlich für die Bauernfamilien für den
ländlichen Raum einsetzt und das
erwarten wir auch von
Ihnen
und im Notfall erwarten wir auch dass
sie ihr Amt zur Disposition stellen wenn
die Regierung der Bundeskanzler der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister
und die Regierung nicht undter
Finanzminister nicht zuhört sie müssen
Druck machen da setzen wir jetzt auf
Sie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und Liebe bauerinnen und Bauern ich habe
am
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister eine
Zusage gemacht nämlich die und dafür
stehe ich und bürge ich dass wir ihn
anständig behandeln dass wir Herrn
östemier
zuhören das er warte ich auch von ihnen
er wird am Ende
sprechen
und Bundesfinanzminister
Lindner den haben wir natürlich auch
eingeladen er hat wegen
Kurzfristigkeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
abgesagt sie werden sich sicherlich auch
die Frage
stellen ist ein Argument oder
interessiert ihnen ih die Anliegen der
Bauernfamilie nicht ich glaube das
letztere ist der
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Fall die FDP ist
angetreten als Partei die zugesichert
hat dass es keine keine
Steuererhöhungen geben wird und was ist
das das ist Steuer Erhöhung das ist
Wortbruch das kann man nicht anders
benennen das ganze wird ja mit dem Thema
Erreichung der Klimaziele begründet ja
der Klimawandel der treibt uns um der
betrifft uns bauernern und beuerinnen
wir arbeiten schon lange dagegen an und
im Gegensatz zu anderen Berufsgruppen zu
anderen Wirtschaftszweigen halten wir
die Klimaziele nicht nur ein wir sind
besser wie das was die Regierung von uns
erwartet bei der Reduktion und ich frage
mich ist das der Dank dafür dass wir so
gut
[Applaus]
sind zu viel ist zu viel es reicht warum
reicht es es reicht auch deshalb weil
wir in den letzten Jahren enorme
zusätzliche Belastungen
hinnehmen mussten beispielsweise bei der
gemeinsamen Agrarpolitik die
administrativ weder auf unseren Höfen
noch in den Amtsstuben umzusetzen ist
die mit praktikabler Landwirtschaft
nichts mehr zu tun hat
beispielsweise diese glötzvorg
bei uns im Betrieb heißen die Mur 1 bis
Mur 8 weil sie schlichtwg Mur
[Applaus]
sind das muss verändert
werden und wir wissen es alle wir waren
die ersten die ein Signal gegeben haben
zu
ökoregelungen wir haben gesagt wir gehen
das wir stärken die Biodiversität und
wir sind auch die einzigen die das auf
der Fläche machen können wir haben die
meisten Blühstreifen weltweit wir haben
den höchsten Anteil an Mulch und
direktsatverfahren wir haben der Politik
das Signal gegeben und was hat sie uns
geliefert Angebote die wir nicht
umsetzen können 400 Millionen Euro
blieben un ursprünglich in Brüssel
liegen weil das nichts mit Praxis zu tun
hat was man uns angeboten hat auch das
muss man
nachbessern und wir waren die die gesagt
haben ja wir bringen mehr Tierwohl in
die Stelle wir haben die Hand angeboten
Minister östemier hat das Problem dass
er das Geld dass er dafür braucht nicht
bekommt dass das gesperrt wird so kann
Tier wohl nicht funktionieren wer den
Porsche will der kann finanziell keinen
Skoda liefern auch hier brauchen wir
zukünftig eine entsprechende
[Applaus]
Unterstützung und die Tierhalter die
kämpfen eh ums Überleben 6,7 Millionen
an Schweinebestand haben wir in 10
Jahren abgebaut 9,2 Millionen haben
unsere spanischen Kollegen aufgebaut die
milchvehhaltung ist stark rückläufig
aber was wirklich in der Seele schmerzt
was mich als Landwirt schmerzt ist dass
wir nach wie vor keine Lösung haben beim
Thema Weidehaltung und Wolf das ist
nicht mehr
[Applaus]
hinnehmbar
4000 Risse pro Jahr sind 4000 Risse zu
viel und wenn wir jetzt nicht die Umkehr
machen wolfsabschuss freigeben dann kann
man in 10 Jahren Deutschland auch
wolfsland nennen und das wollen wir
nicht nicht mit uns Herdenschutz
tierschutz hat und muss Vorrang
haben
[Applaus]
ich kann mich noch gut erinnern März
Bundespressekonferenz die damalige
Bundesregierung war hochnerös man wusste
nicht ob die Versorgung mit
Lebensmitteln sichergestellt werden kann
die Lieferketten sind
abgebrochen die Versorgung war nie
gefährdet warum weshalb weil alle in der
Kette und an erster Stelle wir als
Bauern und Bäuerinnen
247 gearbeitet haben und unsere
Bevölkerung mit hochwertigen heimischen
Lebensmitteln versorgt haben hat man das
schon
[Applaus]
vergessen bei diesem
Vorschlag diesem Vorschlag kann man nur
zu der Erkenntnis kommen dass die
Bundesregierung kein Interesse hat an
einer Versorgung an einer sicheren
Versorgung auf der Basis heimischer
Lebensmittelproduktion dass sie kein
Interesse hat an der Zukunft und der
Zukunftssicherung unserer Betriebe denn
wenn sie es hätte würde sie uns nicht
damit Konf
dass man uns mit einer Milliarde Euro
zusätzlich pro Jahr belasten will das
ist zu viel es
[Applaus]
[Musik]
reicht wir brauchen eine Neuausrichtung
der
Politik eine
Politik die sich wieder den Menschen die
hier in Deutschland leben arbeiten sich
tagtäglich für unser Gemeinwohl
einsetzen dass sie sich diesen wieder
zuwendet dass sie sich die diesen
Menschen wieder
Perspektiven
aufzeigt es geht um die Zukunft unserer
Kinder es geht um die die Zukunft
unserer Enkel es geht schlichtweg um die
Zukunft unseres Deutschlands und da muss
wieder der Fokus
[Applaus]
drauf ich bin ich bin überzeugter
Europäer das sage ich auch an dieser
Stelle Europa die Europäische Union ist
eine
gemeinschaft die brauchen wir die ist
wichtig nicht nur für das friedliche
Zusammenleben die ist wichtig dass wir
auch wirtschaftlich im gemeinsamen
Europa eine Perspektive haben die ist
wichtig
globalpitisch muss Europa auch zukünftig
eine starke Stimme haben aber Europa hat
nur dann Zukunft wenn der ländliche Raum
der stellt 70% von Europa da eine
Zukunft hat und deshalb ist jede
Regierung ob in Brüssel die Europäische
Kommission die regiert Gott sei Dank
nicht richtig aber und nicht wirklich
aber auch die Bundesregierung den
ländlichen Raum und die Bauernfamilien
die das Rückgrat sind Stärken nur dann
hat Deutschland nur dann hat ein starkes
Europa zu dem ich stehe eine
Chance
Liebe Bäuerinnen und Bauern meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren wir sind heute
hier weil das eine Kampfansage der
Regierung war eine Milliarde
Steuererhöhung pro Jahr es reicht es ist
zu viel wir sind aber auch hier
weil wir in den letzten Jahren vieles
erdulden mussten was schlichtweg nicht
hinnehmbar war wir sind aber auch
deshalb hier um natürlich nach vorne zu
blicken worum geht es im Kern nach mir
wird die Landjugend
Vorsitzende ist ja Schmidt sprechen es
geht darum der jungen Generation die
hochmtiviert die top ausgebildet sind
diesen eine
Zukunftsperspektive aufzuzeigen und
dafür braucht's eine verlässliche
Politik dafür braucht's auch
Wertschätzung unserer Arbeit dafür
braucht's aber auch Wertschöpfung damit
die Betriebe in die Zukunft investieren
können da muss vieles gemacht werden
Angebote statt verboten
Lockerungen bei Auflagen anstelle
weiterer
Eingrenzung
verllichkeit es war nicht unser Thema
aber wer ein E-Auto gekauft hat und
jetzt nicht angemeldet hat der guckt in
die Röhre so kann man doch keine Politik
[Applaus]
[Musik]
machen
und ich hätte noch viele Punkte auf der
Agenda aber sind noch weitere
Rednerinnen und Redner da ich werde am
Schluss noch mal was sagen und mich
bedanken dafür dass sie gekommen sind
aber ich will jetzt schon eine Botschaft
setzen lieber Minister
östemier und alle die Verantwortung
tragen hören sie mir gut zu das ist
keine Androhung das ist kein Wink mit
dem Fähnchen das ist eine klare Ansage
wenn diese beiden
Maßnahmen nicht gestrichen werden und
zwar ersatzlos gestrichen werden dann
kommen wir wieder nicht nur nach Berlin
dann werden wir ab 8 Januar überall
präsent sein in einer Art und Weise wie
ist das Land noch noch nicht erlebt hat
wir nehmen das nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hin so meine Damen und Herren das war
der bauernpräsident ruckwied klar aus
seiner Sicht ein klarer ich weiß nicht
ob man das noch Appell nennen kann oder
ein Hinweis oder war es dann doch eine
Drohung auch wenn er gesagt hat es sei
keine wenn diese beiden Subventionen die
gestrichen werden sollen nämlich die
Unterstützung des Diesels und die KFZ
Steuerbegünstigung der Wegfall davon
wenn das nicht jetzt also doch wieder
rückgängig gemacht würde dann käme man
wieder wie es dieses Land noch nie an
Protesten der Bauern erlebt hat das ist
ordentlich Druck ich glaube wir alle
sollten nicht vergessen dass natürlich
das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
dazu geführt hat dass diese Regierung
ihren Haushalt so wie sie ihn vorher
aufgestellt haben nicht mehr halten
konnte deshalb jetzt Milliarden
einsparen muss irgendwo müssen die dann
gespart werden um 12 Uhr sind wir wieder
da denn für diese Uhrzeit hat sich der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister den sie
die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund ja schon
ges